it may be frail but there is still hope
for peace
russian and ukrainian delegations met
for face-to-face talks in istanbul
talking with both parties before the
meeting the turkish president stressed
the need for an immediate ceasefire and
better humanitarian conditions
it'll be in everyone's interest to agree
in a ceasefire and achieve peace as soon
as possible we think you're at a point
where the negotiations could yield
concrete results
right now you as members of the
delegations have a historical
responsibility
before the meeting ukrainian president
vladimir zelansky signaled his
flexibility on the most sensitive issues
including the long contested eastern
donbass region and ukraine's neutral
status
and with its pledge to significantly
decrease military activity near kiev and
in the northern city of chernhee moscow
too is showing signs of a willingness to
compromise
the decision was taken in the interest
of creating mutual trust and the
necessary conditions for further talks
to take place
although its ambition seems diminished
some of russia's demands remain
unchanged russia wants legal guarantees
and a neutrality agreement that ukraine
will never be allowed into nato and it
also wants ukraine to recognize the
independence of the two russian occupied
eastern regions in donbas as well as the
russian-controlled crimea but to achieve
its stated objective of denotifying and
demilitarizing ukraine what russia would
really like is a regime change in
ukraine it's sovereignty beyond
discussion ukraine refuses to even
consider some of these demands
but this relationship with the west is
not one of them
ukrainian officials have proposed
adopting a neutral status only if it
comes with security guarantees similar
to nato's which considers an attack on
one nato country as an attack on the
entire block the proposal also includes
a 15-year consultation period on the
status of russian annex crimea to come
into force only in the event of a
ceasefire
yakshum if we manage to consolidate
these key provisions then ukraine will
be in a position to actually fix its
current status as a non-block and
non-nuclear state in the form of
permanent neutrality we will not host
foreign military bases on our territory
as well as deploy military contingents
in our territory and we will not enter
into military political alliances
as the talks concluded in istanbul
ukraine's immediate goal remained the
same a ceasefire without delay and his
willingness to compromise for it but for
russia to make peace it needs to want it
al jazeera istanbul